تزامنا مع التطورات في روسيا تحدثت القوات
الاوكرانيه عن تمكنها من اختراق تحصينات
روسيه في شرق البلاد والتقدم على جبهات
بخمه المتحدث باسم منطقه عمليات تفاريا
جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا اعلن ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتمكنت من استعاده السيطره على
مواقع باتجاه مدينه دنيسكا كانت تحت سيطره
الانفصاليين والقوات الروسيه منذ عام
2014 واشار المتحدث الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تنفذت هجوما بدعم من الطيران
الحربي والمدفعيه في منطقه كريسنو جريفكا
مكنها من التقدم باتجاه تلك المواقع
وحداتنا الهجوميه نتيجه هجوم مضاد جيد
التخطيط على عده مواقع كانت محتله منذ عام
2014 تابعه لما يسمى بجمهوريه الشعبيه
بالقرب من مدينه
تاخرنا بهذه الاخبار لمده اسبوع لاسباب
تكتيكيه تمكنا من تحرير المواقع بفضل هجوم
نفدناه بدعم الطيران والمعدات الثقيله
وقامت القوات الاوكرانيه بالفعل بازاله
الالغام من بعض المناطق وحداتنا الهجوميه
تقدمت بشكل غير متوقع تماما للعدو ومنذ
اسبوع يتخذ العدو كافه الاجراءات لاخراجنا
من هذه المواقع عن طريق الهجمات اليوميه
والقصف العنيف دون جدوى